vice president mike pence will visit las
vegas today nearly a week after the
sniper shooting
that left 58 dead and injured nearly 500
meanwhile we're learning more about las
vegas gunman stephen paddock's arsenal
and his plans ahead of the deadly sunday
night attack police say these new
details give them
a better profile of paddock but they're
still struggling to uncover his motive
anna werner is outside the mandalay bay
resort and casino near the scene of the
shooting anna good morning
good morning anthony pretty soon people
in las vegas will be seeing billboards
around town telling them
if you know something say something it's
a measure of just how little police know
about why paddock did what he did
we do not still have a clear motive or
reason why
las vegas metro police undersheriff
kevin mcmahill says his department is
following up on more than one thousand
leads
trying to determine stephen paddock's
motive for mass murder we've looked at
everything literally to include the
suspect's personal life
any political affiliation his social
behaviors
but nearly a week after the deadly
shooting investigators remain
frustrated by a lack of clues as to what
prompted the attack
in the past terror attacks or mass
murder incidents
motive was made very clear very clear in
most of those cases by a note that was
left
by a social media post by a telephone
call that was made
by investigators mining computer data
today in our investigation we don't have
any of that uncovered
paddock holed up in a suite at the
mandalay bay casino resort with a load
of weapons including ak-47s and
ar-15s sources tell cbs his arsenal
would have cost
well over 50 thousand dollars
investigators also found paddock's car
in the hotel parking garage
it held an explosive tannerite and at
least a thousand rounds of ammunition
but police say a hero in the form of
security guard jesus campos
likely interrupted his attack campos
went to the 32nd floor to investigate a
door alarm on a room a few doors down
when paddock opened fire hitting him in
the leg
police say his call to dispatch allowed
responding officers to find paddock's
room
i can tell you that this was a
remarkable effort
by a brave and remarkable man meanwhile
the city is honoring those who lost
their lives
volunteers came together to build a
community healing garden that opened
last night
the park includes a wall of remembrance
and a tree
planted for each person killed in sunday
night's tragedy
we're really proud of our city very
proud of how everybody has pulled
together
and tried to help with whatever they can
do
and yet another revelation this morning
this one from the associated press which
reports that investigators are now
interviewing
call girls after learning that paddock
may have hired a prostitute in the days
leading up to the shooting
no one has been identified alex but
they're certainly wanting to talk to
anyone who may have spoken with him
in that time period anna werner in las
vegas thanks anna